il est génial moi je les concerts un peu
à la carte comme ça j'en cf sa vista ans
promène on va écouter un peu à droite à
gauche ça génial 1995 première édition
de la folle journée à nantes et déjà les
musiciens étaient conquis dès le départ
le concept de ce festival de musique
classique fait l'unanimité des concerts
qui ne durent pas plus de 45 minutes des
prix abordables
bref un objectif démocratiser la musique
classique
on a à peine le temps d'aller d'une
salle à l'autre 7 avril au sens très
rapidement le festival nantais s'exporte
au portugal et plus précisément à
lisbonne en 2000 avec le même concept
déplace peu cher et des concerts plus
court que la normale réponse est tombée
les merveilleuses pour que pour is here
is money parce
on a beaucoup de spectacles de musique
classique mais ils sont très chers et
normalement les gens normal non
[Musique]
les gens normaux répondre à l'appel mais
aussi le président du portugal de
l'époque
samedi soir un spectateur qui ne
surprend personne le président de la
république portugaise rock récente par
you
personne
centre culturel et de l'avènement
majeur j'avais
moi qui suis là comme militant de la
musique après lisbonne
il y aura bilbao puis en 2005 le japon
encore un succès car pour 52% des
spectateurs japonais
c'était leur premier concert derrière ce
concept aux nantais qui connaît une
folle expansion
un homme rené martin quand j'explique
une journée pendant deux ou trois ans je
travaille sur comment dirais-je l'esprit
du pays
j'observe la vie musicale la pratique
culturelle et c'est pas et copier coller
ici c'est une vraie folle journée
japonaise la folle journée n'en finit
plus de franchir les frontières
il y aura rio de janeiro en 2007 puis
varsovie en 2010 et plus récemment la
russie une réussite qui n'étonnait pas
ses musiciens très proche de rené martin
en 2009 sa qualité c'est l'invention
sais c'est la générosité c'est la
fidélité
moi j'ai fait savez vous de qualité et
c'est surtout ce que tu dis chaque chose
qu'il entreprend en france mon chemin
j'ai mes enfants tendu un logique c'est
un fait la fois deux journées connaît un
succès à travers le monde
mais son créateur n'en n'oublie pas son
berceau à nantes
c'est devenu un phénomène pour l'édition
2018 135 mille billets ont été vendus et
toujours avec la même philosophie des
concerts de 45 minutes maximum et des
tarifs allant de zéro à maximum 30 euros
[Musique]